This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We have a little different episode for you today. We have two stories. The first is an update to the purple hotel story that was episode number 58 reported by Gwen Maxi. There have been some significant changes since we reported that story. So we wanted to update you on that. But first, I have a short story that I performed live on the radio, on KLW and San Francisco, very, very early in the morning,
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天我们为你准备了一期稍有不同的小节目。我们有两个故事。第一个故事是对第58集紫色酒店故事的更新，该报道由格温·马克辛完成。自从我们报道那个故事以来，情况发生了一些重大变化。所以我们想向大家通报最新的进展。但首先，我有一个短篇故事，是我很久很久以前在清晨的广播中——旧金山的KALW电台——现场表演过的，
but I've never released it as a podcast, so I thought I'd share that one with you today. Here we go. Oman Brownstrother was an undertaker of all things. Kansas City, Missouri got its first telephone exchange in 1878. Telephone service is good for local business, and the funeral business is no exception. But at some point, Almond Brown Stroger of Kansas City noticed that he wasn't getting as many calls from potential customers. He got really suspicious when a friend of the family died and he wasn't getting as many calls from potential customers.
但我从来没有把它作为播客发布过，所以我想今天把它分享给你们。我们开始吧。阿尔曼·布朗斯特罗格是一位名副其实的殡仪馆老板。密苏里州堪萨斯城在1878年迎来了它的第一个电话交换所。电话业务对本地商业大有裨益，殡葬业务也不例外。但在某个时候，堪萨斯城的阿尔曼·布朗斯特罗格注意到，他接到的潜在客户电话没有以前那么多了。当一个家族朋友去世，而他却
He got really suspicious when a friend of the family died and he wasn't even called about performing the funeral services. The story goes, and the story is really hard to verify, but I'm going to go with it because I really like it. The story goes that after some poking around, Stroger discovered that the wife of a rival undertaker in the area was an operator for the local telephone company. At the time, telephones were connected manually by female operators patching lines together
甚至没有接到承办葬礼业务的电话时，他开始感到非常怀疑。故事是这样的——这个故事很难核实，但我还是决定讲它，因为我真的很喜欢。故事流传，在一番明察暗访后，斯特罗格发现当地一家竞争对手殡仪馆老板的妻子，恰好是当地电话公司的一名接线员。在当时，电话是由女接线员手动连接的，她们将线路插在
on a gigantic punchboard. Someone would pick up the receiver, asking for the local undertaker in general or even Stroger in particular, and in this case, the unscrupulous operator would only connect the call to her husband's undertaking business, not to strogers. And stroger figured it out. If you are all-man-brown stroger, Kansas City undertaker, there are a few ways you can go when you discover something like this. Number one. And it's number one for a reason, because it makes the most sense.
一个巨大的配线板上。有人拿起听筒，要求接通当地的一般殡仪馆甚至是斯特罗格本人，而在这种情况下，这位不道德的接线员只会把电话转接到她丈夫的殡葬业务，而不是斯特罗格的。而斯特罗格发现了这一点。如果你是阿尔曼·布朗斯特罗格，堪萨斯城的殡仪馆老板，当你发现这样的事情时，你有几种应对方式。第一种。而且它排在第一位是有原因的，因为它最合乎情理。
You can contact the local telephone company and alert them about the dishonest operator in their employ. Maybe even get her fired. Number two, you can take her in her husband's civil court. Try to sue for damages or something. Or there's always option number three. You can invent an automatic telephone switching system that allows people to dial each other directly,
你可以联系当地电话公司，向他们举报雇员中的这个不诚实接线员。甚至可能让她被解雇。第二种，你可以把她和她丈夫告上民事法庭。试图起诉要求损害赔偿或什么的。或者还有第三种选择。你可以发明一个自动电话交换系统，允许人们直接拨打对方的电话，
eliminating any need for a telephone switchboard operator and thereby completely revolutionizing the entire telephone system forever. Almond Brown Stroger, the undertaker, went with option number three. He wasn't the first to come up with the idea, but his concept was the first automatic switcher that worked for more than a handful of phones
从而彻底消除了对电话交换台接线员的需求，并由此永远彻底地革新了整个电话系统。身为殡仪馆老板的阿尔曼·布朗斯特罗格，选择了第三种方案。他并不是想出这个点子的第一人，但他的概念是第一个适用于系统中不止寥寥几部电话的
within a system. He was awarded a patent in 1891. Of course, he didn't know how to make the thing. He was an Undertaker, if I haven't stressed that enough already. Stroder conscripted his nephew and some business partners to help develop a working prototype. It cost more and took longer than anyone anticipated, but they finally got it working, and they
实用自动交换机。他在1891年被授予专利。当然，他并不知道怎么制造这东西。他是个殡仪馆老板，如果我刚才还没强调够的话。斯特罗格召集了他的侄子和一些商业伙伴来帮忙开发一个工作原型。这比任何人预期的花费更多、时间更长，但他们最终让它运转起来，并且
finally got a chance to try it out in the real world. Le Port, Indiana, became the first place to have automatic, operator-free telephone dialing. In a speech at the unveiling of the Laporte telephone exchange, the cantankerist, droger, addressed the issue of the hello girls, the operators who would lose their jobs because of his automated switch. Quote, I'm often told that the telephone girls will be angry with me, burrowing them of their
终于有机会在现实世界中对其进行测试。印第安纳州的拉波特，成了第一个拥有自动、无需接线员的电话拨号地方。在拉波特电话交换所开幕式的一场演讲中，这位脾气暴躁的斯特罗格谈到了“电报女孩”的问题——那些因为他的自动交换机而失去工作的接线员。引用他的话说：“我常听人说，电话小姐们会对我感到生气，因为我剥夺了她们的
occupation. In reply, I say that all things will adjust themselves to the new order. Water will find its level. The telephone replace the messenger boy as this machine now displaces the telephone girl. Improvements will continue to the end of time, strike where they may. The Bell telephone company eventually acquired the technology in 1916, and the Stroger Switch, as it was called, became standard equipment throughout the 20th century. So up next I'm going to play you episode number 58 again. It's called Purple Rain about the Purple Hotel reported by a Gwen Maxine.
职业。作为回应，我说一切事物都会适应新的秩序。水会找到它自己的水平面。电话取代了信差男孩，就像这个机器现在取代了电话小姐一样。改进将持续到时间的尽头，管它打击到谁。”贝尔电话公司最终在1916年收购了这项技术，而被称为“斯特罗格交换机”的设备，成了整个20世纪的标准设备。接下来我要再次为你播放第58集。它是由格温·马克辛报道的、关于紫色酒店的《紫雨》。
And then we're going to have a really, really significant, you know, like four or five minute update about what happened to the purple hotel since this was first reported. So stay tuned for that. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The hotel on the very prominent corner of Tué and Kilburn Avenue in Lincolnwood, Illinois used to be the town's most famous building. The first high at Hotel in all of Chicago land, premier accommodations, top notch restaurant. It was Swank, Roberta Flack stayed there, Barry Manelow stayed there,
然后我们会有非常非常重要的，大概四五分钟的更新，讲述自从首次报道以来紫色酒店发生了什么。所以请收听接下来的内容。这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。伊利诺伊州林肯伍德图伊大街和基尔本大街交汇处那座显眼的酒店，曾经是该镇最著名的建筑。整个芝加哥地区第一家凯悦酒店，一流的住宿，顶级的餐厅。它非常时髦，罗伯塔·弗莱克在那儿住过，巴里·曼尼洛在那儿住过，
Perry Como, Michael Jordan stayed there on his first night in Chicago. And every 13 year old boy in the area had his permits for there. The hotel was built in 1960, and it looks it. So if you're wondering how much potentially anachronistic lounge music I'm going to cram into this episode, oh, it's going to be a lot.
佩里·科莫、迈克尔·乔丹在芝加哥的第一晚也住在那儿。当地的每一个13岁男孩都在那儿办过派对。这家酒店建于1960年代，它看起来也确实如此。所以如果你在想我要把多少潜在的时代错误休息室音乐塞进这一集里，哦，那可有得受了。
Then slowly over time, it became Lincoln Woods' most infamous building. It changed hands, got seedy, and run down. It was the home of the Midwest fetish fair and marketplace convention. There were drug-fueled sex parties tended by shady Chicago politicians later convicted of things like extortion, and of course there was the convicted mobster Alan Dorfman, who was gunned down in the parking lot. But that's not why everyone in the area knows the building. If you know nothing of its history, it's still pretty hard to miss.
然后慢慢地，随着时间的推移，它成了林肯伍德最声名狼藉的建筑。它几经易手，变得破败不堪。这里曾是中西部恋物癖展销会和集市大会的举办地。这里有过充满毒品的性派对，由后来因敲诈勒索等罪名被定罪的阴暗芝加哥政客参与，当然，还有被定罪的黑帮分子艾伦·多夫曼，他在停车场被枪杀。但这不是当地人认识这座建筑的原因。如果你对它的历史一无所知，它依然很难被忽视。
Because it's purple. Really, really purple. Growing up nearby, I always thought it was really, really purple. Growing up nearby, I always thought it was really, really ugly. Lots of people did. To be fair, lots of people didn't, but everyone had an opinion about it. But Gwen Maxine, that's what I'm talking to now, by the way, noted S.A.S. in public video host, and she even created a sitcom once. She has a secret about the purple hotel.
因为它太紫了。真的，非常紫。在附近长大的我，一直觉得它真的非常紫。在附近长大的我，一直觉得它真的非常丑。很多人都这么觉得。公平地说，也有很多人不这么觉得，但每个人对它都有看法。但是格温·马克辛——顺便说一下，我现在正在和她说话，她是一位著名的电视节目主持人，甚至还创作过一次情景喜剧——她对紫色酒店有一个秘密。
My father designed it. My name is Jan Max. I'm a retired architect and former professor at UIC. I designed a lot of just a building. I'm talking about it. Nothing interrupts. I'm going to do a lot of... Just the building we're talking about. Huh? Don't interrupt. I don't have time for the long bio, Dad. Okay, I designed a lot of apartment buildings in Chicago.
我父亲设计了它。我叫扬·马克克斯。我是UIC（伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校）的退休建筑师和前教授。我设计了很多——只是一座建筑。我在说这个。没有什么能打断。我要做很多……就我们正在谈论的建筑。啊？别打断。我没有时间讲冗长的生平，爸爸。好吧，我在芝加哥设计了许多公寓楼。
We're here to talk about the purple hotel. I need to say, I designed... My name is John Maxx, I'm an architect. I designed the purple hotel. My name is John Maxx, I'm an an architect and I was the designer of the purple of the top. Finally, now you have to understand that when I say the building is purple, I don't mean the kind of purple of say an iris or a plum. It's purple as in lavender. Lavender purple glazed brick all over pretty much the entire thing. Which Needless to say makes it stand out.
我们是来谈紫色酒店的。我需要说，我设计了……我叫约翰·马克克斯，我是一名建筑师。我设计了紫色酒店。我叫约翰·马克克斯，我是一名建筑师，我是那个顶……紫色的设计者。最后，现在你必须明白，当我说这座建筑是紫色时，我指的不是那种比如鸢尾花或李子的紫色。它是薰衣草紫。差不多整个建筑到处都是薰衣草紫色的釉面砖。这不用说也知道，让它格外显眼。
Depending on how you look at it, like a prize jewel or a sore thumb. You know, that's one of the few buildings that if you see it once, you know, it's, you've seen it forever, you can't, you know, get the image of it all the way around. It is so purple that after it changed hands, the new owners renamed it the Purple Hotel. WB Easy Architecture Critic, Leigh Bay. I think that it's worth looking at absent the brick. The brick I like, but I wish you could sort of put on glasses. I could filter it out so you don't see the brick at least in one trip.
取决于你看它的角度，它像一颗珍贵的宝石，还是像眼中钉。你知道，那是为数不多的建筑之一，如果你看它一眼，你知道，它是——你永远都忘不了，你不能——你知道，它的形象挥之不去。它是如此之紫，以至于在它易手后，新业主将其重新命名为紫色酒店。WBEE建筑评论家，利·贝伊。我认为即使抛开砖块来看，它也是值得一看的。砖块我很喜欢，但我希望你能戴上某种眼镜。我可以把它过滤掉，这样至少在看一眼时你就看不到砖块了。
And really see how the building holds this up together structurally. I mean, I think it's really good. The way that John was able to put those supports on the outside of the hotel to give larger floor plates in the middle, which is what you want. You want big functional spaces inside of a hotel. And then again, the little nooks of green space
并且真正看看这座建筑在结构上是如何支撑起这一切的。我的意思是，我认为这真的很棒。约翰能够在酒店外部设置那些支撑柱，从而在中间提供更大的楼层平面，这正是你想要的。你希望酒店内部有巨大的功能空间。然后，还有绿化空间的小角落
and the way that the sort of the building's kind of fit together, the complex fits together. I mean, really, there's really a lot of good things going on there. I say, come for the purple, but stay for the architecture. The thing that everybody notices first, including architects, would be the color. I mean, I think that if anybody's saying that it's not
以及建筑彼此契合的方式，综合体拼合在一起的方式。我的意思是，真的，那里确实有很多精彩之处。我说，为紫色而来，为建筑而留。每个人首先注意到的东西，包括建筑师在内，就是颜色。我的意思是，我认为如果有人说这不是
the color that they're lying, because you can't really look at the building without noticing that it's purple. So it's the only purple building around. But then after that initial wave of color hits, you notice really what a great modernist structure it has and how the structure is expressed on the outside, which is also not something you see every day anymore. And I think it's a wonderful building. That was Jackie Kuh, founding principal of the architectural firm Kuhn Associates. We'll
颜色，那他们在撒谎，因为你不可能在不注意到它是紫色的话题下看这座建筑。所以它是周围唯一的紫色建筑。但在那最初的色彩冲击波过后，你会真正注意到它是一座多么棒的现代主义结构，以及结构是如何在外表上表现出来的，这也是你现在不常见到的。我认为这是一座绝妙的建筑。那是Kuhn Associates建筑事务所的创始合伙人杰姬·库。我们一会儿
get back to her in a minute. But first, the story of why and how the building got to be so purple. My dad, John Maxine. It was commissioned by the Pritzkurs, the very rich family in Chicago, and it was the first Hyatt Hotel in the Midwest. It was called Hyattaz. Nothing to do with the purple. By the way, the purple came because one of the Pritzkers, A.N., the big man among the Pritzkers in the family, as we, what color-glace style I want to use. I wanted to use gray, and he said, that's dull. I like something brighter. So I made a mistake of showing him the samples of books having on it some 35, 40 colored samples. And sure enough, you picked the purple.
会回到她那里。但首先，讲讲这座建筑为什么以及如何变得如此之紫的故事。我的父亲，约翰·马克辛。它是应芝加哥非常富有的家族普利茨克家族之邀而建造的，它是中西部第一家凯悦酒店。它当时叫凯悦（Hyatt House）。与紫色毫无关系。顺便说一下，紫色的由来是因为普利茨克家族的一位成员，A.N.，普利茨克家族中的大人物，当时我们……我想用什么颜色的釉面风格。我想用灰色，而他说，那太沉闷了。我喜欢亮一点的。于是我犯了个错误，给他看了带有大约35、40种颜色样本的书。果不其然，他挑了紫色。
And you don't argue with Ian Fritzker. and Friskard. My father tells me this story, but I suspect differently. He's always gravitated toward bold color choices. Our current argument is over bright orange balconies on a building that we always pass, he loves them, and I hate them. When I was growing up, his favorite color was blue. A color that, to me, is suspiciously close to purple. In fact, every house we ever lived in,
你可不会和安·普利茨克争辩。和普利茨克。我父亲给我讲了这个故事，但我的直觉不同。他总是倾向于大胆的色彩选择。我们目前的争论在于我们总是路过的一栋建筑上亮橙色的阳台，他很喜欢，而我很讨厌。我小时候，他最喜欢的颜色是蓝色。在我看来，这个颜色可疑地接近紫色。事实上，我们住过的每一栋房子，
brick bungalow, summer house in the woods, suburban barn-shaped house with mustard colored siding, all had bright blue front doors. That my father painted. My elementary school bus driver used to call me Blue Door. Upon interrogation, my father coughed up his strange Hungarian logic. In the Near East, where ultimately I come from, the blue color on the doors, blue and green,
砖砌平房、树林里的避暑别墅、有着芥末色护墙板的郊区谷仓形房子，都有亮蓝色的前门。都是我父亲漆的。我小学的校车司机以前叫我“蓝门”。在盘问之下，我父亲吐露了他奇怪的匈牙利逻辑。在中东，也就是我最终的故乡，门上的蓝色，蓝色和绿色，
is to keep the evil spirit away. So that's a reason I always expected the entrance door of a house's blue to keep the evils spirit away. And they did. Do you think it worked for the hotel? So you don't think the purple kept away the evil eye from the hotel? Not really, because there was a murder in the hotel. Actually, there were two, but I digress. The beauty of that building is the exposed concrete frame. How the columns are pulled out of the structure, showing this... It's like a human being whose skeleton will be on the exterior partially.
是为了驱赶恶魔。所以这就是为什么我一直期望房子的入口门是蓝色的，用来驱魔。它们确实做到了。你觉得它对酒店也管用吗？所以你不认为紫色为酒店挡住了恶魔的眼睛吗？其实没有，因为酒店里发生过谋杀案。实际上，有两起，但我扯远了。那栋建筑的美妙之处在于外露的混凝土框架。柱子是如何从结构中抽离出来的，展现出这个……这就像一个人的骨骼部分露在外面。
That will be weird, right? Well, that's the way that building is. The columns are pulled out, the slabs are slightly pulled out. It's a building which reveals its structure. And that is architecturally the interesting thing about it. The purple is totally irrelevant. It could be green, okay? It would be the same good or bad building. So as an architect, I have to ask you, this is a perfect example of what the difference between what the public sees and what the architect sees. Oh, absolutely. Because the public sees Purple Brick, the architect is sitting here saying
那会很诡异，对吧？好吧，那栋建筑就是那样的。柱子被抽离了，楼板也被稍微抽离了。这是一座展现其结构的建筑。从建筑学上讲，这才是它有趣的地方。紫色完全无关紧要。它可以是绿色的，好吧？它作为好或坏的建筑都是一样的。所以作为一名建筑师，我必须问你，这是一个完美的例子，说明了公众看到的和建筑师看到的有什么区别。哦，绝对是的。因为公众看到的是紫色砖块，而建筑师坐在这里说
the purple is so unimportant in the scheme of the building. It means nothing. It's just such a tiny thing. But to the public, that's all it is. That's right, because the public is ignorant. That truly ignorant. Well, you can't really argue with them there, but in our defense and I count myself as one of the public in the scenario, it's really, really purple. And despite how far the purple hotel fell from its original glory, the dilapidation, the murder, the drug-fueled
紫色在建筑的整体规划中是如此不重要。它毫无意义。它只是一件微不足道的小事。但对公众来说，这就是全部。没错，因为公众是无知的。真正无知的。好吧，在这点上你真的无法反驳他们，但在我们为自己辩护时——我在这场情景中把自己算作公众的一部分——它真的、真的很紫色。尽管紫色酒店从昔日的辉煌中跌落，经历了破败、谋杀、毒品引发的
sex parties, and a demolition order. It was not torn down. Time passed. The economy fell to pieces. Mid-century architecture slowly came back into Vogue. Mad Men was on TV. The Purple Brick was kind of retro-cool. A light, however, dim was starting to shine on the building in its future. Then, the Purple Hotel was nominated for landmark status, a place on the historic registry. There was talk of finding a buyer, talk of renovation, and then while I was searching and interviewing for this very story, the Purple Hotel went up for auction. There was a lot of pomp and circumstance in the beginning of, you know, the auctioneer yelling and saying,
性派对以及拆迁令。它并没有被拆除。时间流逝。经济分崩离析。世纪中期现代主义建筑慢慢重新流行起来。电视里在播《广告狂人》。紫色砖块带有一种复古酷感。一束虽微弱但开始照耀这座建筑及其未来的光芒正在出现。然后，紫色酒店被提名具有地标地位，列入历史名册。有传言称要寻找买家，有传言称要进行翻新，然后，就在我为这个故事进行搜寻和采访时，紫色酒店被拍卖了。拍卖开始时有很多大肆宣传和仪式感，你知道的，拍卖师大喊大叫着说，
are you ready and, you know, in the booming voice and then, and then really there was only one bitter, so. And that bitter was Jake Weiss, of Weiss properties in Skokie, which happens to be right next to Lincolnwood. He bought the purple hotel, and while Weiss is a shrewd businessman with a keen eye and good instincts, this particular purchase was also a labor of love. When you have something that really is just not realizing its value and its potential that has such a prime piece of property, it bothers you, you know, it's part of your neighbor,
你们准备好了吗，你知道的，用洪亮的声音，然后，然后实际上只有一个竞标者，所以。而那个竞标者是斯基考威斯地产公司的杰克·怀斯，斯基考恰好就在林肯wood旁边。他买下了紫色酒店，虽然怀斯是一个目光敏锐、直觉良好的精明商人，但这次特殊的购买也是出于热爱。当你拥有某样东西，它确实没有意识到自己的价值和潜力，却占据着如此黄金的地段，这会让你心烦，你知道的，它是你邻居的一部分，
it's part of your community, and it's something that you really want to see be an asset to the community instead of a blight. Here comes the love part. Separately from that, when my, and more importantly, I think, we almost lived at the purple hotel for a period of time, when my grandfather had passed away and my father was saying the traditional codish. That's the Jewish prayer for the dead. There was no synagogue anywhere in close proximity to where he lived at the time. And because we're Orthodox and we're gonna drive on a Sabbath, that was a little bit prohibitive to say the kathish.
它是你社区的一部分，是你真正希望看到成为社区资产而不是荒地的事物。爱心部分来了。除此之外，当我的——更重要的是，我认为，我们在紫色酒店几乎住过一段时间，当时我祖父去世了，我父亲正在念传统的卡迪什。那是犹太人的悼亡经。在他当时居住的地方附近没有任何犹太会堂。因为我们是正统派，我们不会在安息日开车，这在念卡迪什方面有点阻碍。
There's a very convenient shoulder right down the block. Also known as a synagogue. The congregation, you who in Amosha, so on every single shop is for a year, we would move into the purple hotel to accommodate my father's responsibility to say the cuddish for his father. So we lived there for about a year every single weekend and you know me and my sister the hotel was our playground. And the architect Wys has chosen to redesign the purple hotel and bring it back to its original luster is Jackie Kuh of Jackie Kuh and associates. Also, a former student of my father, the original architect, John Maxi.
街区尽头有一个非常方便的犹太会堂。也被称为犹太会堂。会众，在每一个安息日持续一年，我们会搬进紫色酒店，以适应我父亲为他父亲念卡迪什的责任。所以我们在那里大约住了一年，每个周末都是如此，你懂的，我和我妹妹，酒店就是我们的游乐场。而怀斯选择重新设计紫色酒店并使其恢复昔日光彩的建筑师是杰姬·库和合伙人的杰姬·库。她也是我父亲——最初的建筑师约翰·马克辛——的前学生。
One of the things that we're looking into is more of a historic restoration of the building. It would be wonderful, and especially since we have some of the old drawings, the original drawings from the 60s. And there are a lot of pieces that are still left in the building such as this wonderful monumental Tarazo stair with this wood wall behind it. I mean you can really see it as this kind of you know late 50s, early 60s kind of madmen era, panam sort of hotel that really could be very current in today's hospitality environment. The culture today, especially in the hospitality market, for somebody's imperposed a predominant color, not necessarily in the color of the brick, but in all their marketing.
我们正在研究的事情之一是对建筑进行更多历史意义上的修复。这将是美妙的，特别是既然我们拥有一些旧图纸，来自60年代的原始图纸。并且建筑中仍有许多留存的部件，比如这个奇妙的不朽水磨石楼梯，背后还有这面木墙。我的意思是，你可以真正把它看作是那种，你知道的，50年代末、60年代初的那种《广告狂人》时代的泛美航空式的酒店，在当今的酒店业环境中确实可以非常现代。当今的文化，特别是在酒店业市场，对于有人强加一种主导色彩，不一定是在砖的颜色上，而是在他们所有的营销中。
I mean, you'll look at the neon lights and the color of the key fob cards and the brochures that get printed for some reason, purple is popping, and I'm not quite sure why. Have any of your buildings had this kind of history, this kind of life cycle that you know of? No, none of them. The same way that a person they go through life and you might go through different cycles
我的意思是，你会看看霓虹灯、钥匙扣卡的颜色以及印出来的宣传册，出于某种原因，紫色正在流行，我不太确定为什么。你的建筑中有没有过这种历史，这种你所知道的生命周期？不，没有。就像一个人经历人生，你可能自己也经历不同的周期
yourself and everybody goes through different rebellious times and ups and downs, I think the same holds true for a proper like this that really was a character of itself. The building was really a product of the environment around it at any given time, and to a certain extent the fact that the building did change with the decades and the environment around it, it really is the building's character. And while it's true that this character, this building, this structure of nine lives sits empty at the moment, surrounded by bored traffic and an empty parking lot, it may just be crouching,
每个人都会经历不同的叛逆期和起起落落，我认为对于像这样真正具有自身个性的物业来说也是如此。这座建筑确实是在任何特定时间周围环境的产物，并在某种程度上，这座建筑随着几十年及其周围环境而改变的事实，确实就是这座建筑的个性。虽然事实是，这个个性、这座建筑、这座经历了九条命的建筑目前空置着，周围是无聊的交通和空旷的停车场，但它可能正蹲伏着，
gathering its muster ready to spring back to life, arresting that traffic, filling that parking lot, and strutting like a proud peacock. A Purple One. a purple one. I'd like to thank Red Mandel from National Reckon Company for doing all that he and his company could do to make this day a reality. Here we go! Yeah baby! So it turns out that after all of the gargantuan efforts to save the purple hotel, it would have cost 40 some million dollars. That's a million within that.
积蓄力量，准备重新焕发生机，震慑交通，填满停车场，像骄傲的孔雀一样挺胸阔步。一只紫色的。一只紫色的。我要感谢国家搜救公司的雷·曼德尔，感谢他和他的公司为使这一天成为现实所做的一切努力。我们走吧！耶，宝贝！事实证明，在为拯救紫色酒店做出了所有浩大的努力之后，它将耗资4000多万美元。其中包含一百万。
Actually, it was over 40 million dollars. It was just cost prohibitive. So despite so much goodwill on the part of so many people who wanted to see it survive, the purple hotel was torn down. Or I should say is in the process of being torn down. But at least the process of tearing the purple hotel down began with some ceremony. If everybody could start finding a seat, we're going to get started. On August 27, 2013, the parking lot of the Purple Hotel was filled with local dignitaries from Lincolnwood, Illinois. Even the mayor was there.
事实上，它超过了4000万美元。成本实在太高了。因此，尽管有这么多人希望它能存活下来的良好愿望，紫色酒店还是被拆除了。或者我应该说正在被拆除的过程中。但至少拆除紫色酒店的过程是以某种仪式开始的。如果大家能开始找座位坐下，我们要开始了。2013年8月27日，紫色酒店的停车场挤满了来自伊利诺伊州林肯伍德的当地政要。连市长也在场。
Thank you so much for being here, Mayor. So on the day of the demolition, it was really, really beautiful. They had a huge white tent. They had purple flowers. They had purple napkins. They gave my dad a purple brick with a plaque on it. I mean, it was just really, really beautifully done and it was a loving tribute to the building. At the same time, it was a little bit like going to synagogue
非常感谢你们的到来，市长。所以在拆迁的那天，天气真的、真的很美。他们搭了一个巨大的白色帐篷。他们有紫色的花。他们有紫色的餐巾。他们送给我爸爸一块带有牌匾的紫色砖块。我的意思是，这真的、真的很精美，这是对这座建筑充满爱意的致敬。与此同时，这有点像去犹太会堂
because Lincoln Wood is a predominantly Jewish suburb, or at least it was, and so all the people who had such strong feelings about the building, largely were Jewish. OK, good morning, good morning, everyone. Thank you all for coming to my bar mitzvah today. But this wasn't exactly a bar mitzvah. When John Maxx took the stage, he said it was a little more like another ride of passage. It's a little bit like being invited for your own funeral, which by the way cannot be
因为林肯伍德是一个以犹太人为主的郊区，或者至少曾经是，所以所有对这座建筑有如此强烈感情的人，很大程度上都是犹太人。好吧，早安，大家早安。谢谢大家今天来参加我的成年礼。但这不完全是一个成年礼。当约翰·马克辛走上舞台时，他说这更像是另一种成年仪式。这有点像被邀请去参加你自己的葬礼，顺便说一句，这是无法
avoided. Kind of curious thing that an architect is invited to the tearing down of his building. The typical moment of piece of architecture and a piece of journalism coincide is when the building is first constructed. This is like writing the biography of a person, the moment that he or she is born. The real story is how the structure influences the environment, how it grows up, how it sports and changes, and even how it dies. Though this wasn't really the end of the purple hotel anyway, the wrecking ball took a couple of wax at the building and then they stopped.
避免的。一个建筑师被邀请去拆毁他自己的建筑，这是一件挺奇怪的事情。一个建筑作品和一篇新闻报道相吻合的典型时刻是建筑初建之时。这就像是在一个人出生的一瞬间为他写传记。真正的故事是这个结构如何影响环境，它如何长大，它如何繁衍和改变，甚至它是如何死去的。不过这其实并不是紫色酒店的终结，拆楼球对建筑砸了几下然后就停了。
It's going to take five months to tear it down because 75% of it needs to be recycled as a matter of law. Brick by purple brick, they're taking it down. So the bricks would just get thrown into a big pile and shipped off to wherever they get recycled. If there wasn't such a high demand for them. It turns out that everybody and their brother wants a purple brick. I was married at that hotel. I lost my virginity at that hotel. I used to go to that hotel every weekend with my parents.
拆除它需要五个月的时间，因为按法律规定，75%的建筑必须被回收利用。一块接一块紫色砖头，他们正在把它拆掉。所以这些砖块就会被扔进一大堆里，运到某个地方去回收。如果它们没有这么高的需求的话。事实证明，每个人和他们的兄弟都想要一块紫色砖。我就是在那个酒店结的婚。我在那个酒店失去了童贞。我以前每个周末都和父母一起去那个酒店。
I played in the pool at that hotel. I heard Roberta Flack at that hotel, I mean everybody has a memory associated with it, and so everybody wants a brick. And I can't even tell you how many people have asked me for a brick. Not the least of which I might add was you. Oh, I want a purple brick so badly. Um, I'm gonna get you at least a chip, if not a brick.
我在那个酒店的游泳池里玩耍。我在那个酒店听过罗伯塔·弗莱克的歌，我的意思是每个人都有一段与之相关的记忆，所以每个人都想要一块砖。我甚至无法告诉你有多少人向我讨要砖块。我得补充一句，其中绝不乏你。哦，我太想要一块紫色的砖了。嗯，我会至少给你弄个碎片，如果不是整砖的话。
As long as it has some purple on it. It will have the iconic purple glaze on it. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Gwen Maxx, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio, KALW, and San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco in the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars. Sam Green's band tweets at Sam listens. Right now you can find pictures of the destruction of the purple hotel
只要上面有一点紫色就行。它会带有标志性的紫色釉面。本周的《99%隐形》由格温·马克辛、山姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是91.7本地公共广播电台、旧金山KALW电台以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我在推特上的账号是Roman Mars。山姆·格林斯潘在推特上的账号是Sam listens。现在你可以在99percentinvisible.org上找到紫色酒店被毁的照片
and also some nice pictures of it in its heyday at 99%invisible.org. The Bender Listening to right now is called OK Akumi. We use a lot of them on this radio program along with bands like Lullatone and Melodian and Orcas. If you want to score your life like an episode of 99% Invisible, go to our web page is 99pi.org and look for our Spotify playlist. And then go buy something of theirs because all these bands are awesome. Thanks! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及它全盛时期的一些漂亮照片。你现在听到的这首曲子叫《OK Akumi》。我们在广播节目中经常使用它们，还有像Lullatone、Melodian和Orcas这样的乐队。如果你想为你的生活配乐，就像《99%隐形》的一集一样，请访问我们的网页99pi.org并寻找我们的Spotify播放列表。然后去买一些他们的音乐，因为所有这些乐队都太棒了。谢谢！本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。